the story starts with a red tinted sky
on a remote farming Village somewhere in
a Japan
the entire Village first appears
abandoned and desolate but a closer
glance reveals that nearly all the
villagers have been turned into corpses
the scream pans out to reveal that the
corpses appear to be crawling in a
certain direction at the center of the
corpses on the path is a little girl
wearing a traditional Miko dress
she appears to have been the objective
of the now dead villagers back in
present day at Academy City Toma and
index are waiting to cross the road when
Tomah complains about how expensive the
reference book he bought is
their argument is interrupted by the
appearance of moto Haru and oligami
Tomo's classmates from before his memory
loss they ask who the girl is Alabama
comments on his dull reaction and jokes
that he may have lost his memories in
the restaurant index seems pretty
content with tomah's decision but he is
exasperated having to treat not only
index but alagami and modoharu as well
index then directs Toma to an occupied
table where a suspicious looking girl is
sitting with her head in her arms Toma
asks the girl what the problem is to
which she replies that she has spent all
her money on food she says that she
doesn't have enough money for the train
and Thomas suggests that she should just
borrow it from someone matoharu and
ahagami are amazed at how lovely she is
and the latter takes a picture of her
she then asked both modoharu and aagami
for money to lend to her especially the
latter who has taken pictures of her
however index gets fed up with her and
comments on how Shrine girls sell their
faces in the city too shikami tells
index that she is not a shrine girl but
is in fact a magician their conversation
is interrupted by the arrival of several
men in suits apparently acquaintances of
the girl which she confirms by asking
money from them and saying that they are
her cram school teachers she then leaves
with the men prompting AG gaming to ask
why a cram school teacher would be
looking after a student
later index finds a stray calico cat
inside of box and Tomah rejects the idea
of taking it home the cat runs away
while they're arguing an index tries to
go after it however soon after she has
left Toma suddenly feels uneasiness in
his surroundings and is greeted by a
tall man with red hair who seems to know
him his name is Style Style says that
you should be familiar with this spell
that removes unwanted people from an
area leaving Toma and style alone Toma
wonders who the person before him is and
is cautious in speaking with him style
interprets this as a sign that Toma
still does not like or trust him which
he understands Toma then asks style what
he wants from him but mistakenly Smiles
while doing so prompting style to attack
him with his fire magic Tomo was quick
enough to block it and is then told by
style that is how their relationship
should be not friends
style then informs Toma about Masala
cram school which has recently become a
sort of religious cult and has also
imprisoned a girl style says that the
reason the school was in its current
state is that it was taken over by an
alchemist oreolus style continues as
explanation saying that the Alchemist
has been in hiding for three years and
is now back for the girl imprisoned in
Missoula kram School nicknamed deep
blood style says that deep blood
possesses the ability to kill a certain
organism vampires and is what Orioles is
after after his explanation Tomah asks
what he wants from him and style states
that he is on a mission to attack miss
our cram school and rescue deep blood
and that Toma is going with him or else
index will be taken away back in his
dormitory Tomah discovers the index has
brought in the cat from early as Tomah
leaves his apartment he finds style
applying runes that will summon
inocentious in the area outside his door
as an extra precaution against magicians
style notes how Troublesome index is to
look after they eventually arrive at the
KREM School in style notes that the
entire building has become The Alchemist
seal Tomah asks style if Orioles is
strong and style confirms this by saying
that he has achieved the ultimate goal
of Alchemists the power to model
anything in this world the power to
bring out anything they imagine into
reality style then shows the picture of
the imprisoned girl they are going to
rescue to Tomah tomagasts as style says
that her name is Aza it's the girl Toma
met earlier at the restaurant KOMO and
Style walk into the school and notice a
figure in Knight's armor lying slumped
over next to a column in the school
Lobby coma thinks that it is a robot but
style tells him that it is a corpse
lying a pool of its own blood
Toma asks why no one notices the corpse
in the school to which style States it's
because Orioles has put a seal in the
school and that they need to defeat
Orioles to break it they move to the
stairs and Tomah wonders why they aren't
using the elevators style tells him that
they can't use equipment that is on the
outer side while they are on the inner
side
they later arrive in a cafeteria where
they suddenly discover that the students
have noticed their presence and are in
some sort of Trance style states that
the students have been placed on the
inner side of the coin as an automated
alarm system the students start standing
up and begin doing an incantation
glowing blue spheres start coming out of
the student's foreheads while they're
doing the incantation style states that
it's time for Tomah to do something and
runs away but Tomah realizes that his
power is not enough to counter that many
separate magic spheres and runs away as
well catching up to style who argues
with him about why he is running away
somehow while running style is able to
explain to Toma that the espers are
using a replica of gregorio's core style
says that it is a grand magic spell that
requires 3 333 monks to pray together in
a cathedral to defeat it he says one
must simply defeat whatever is
synchronizing all of them style and
Tomah reach a staircase and her style
uses Toma as bait to run away while
running from the Spheres Houma comes
across a girl surrounded by the Spheres
she chants an incantation while doing so
it creates several cuts on her person
Toma tries to tell her to stop the girl
suddenly collapses and Toma tries to
break her fall while doing so the
Spheres that surrounded them are now
moving erratically squirreling around
and then suddenly launching themselves
to Toma but they suddenly stop and
slowly fall down to the floor and
disappear Tomah Hears A noise and
turning around seesa meanwhile style is
burning a symbol off of a wall with his
fire magic he comments on how messed up
Orioles is for using students to help
him instead of doing it on his own
however this is overheard and commented
on by Orioles himself he postulates that
the Intruder that came with style may
have been devoured by gregorio's replica
style responds that Tomah will not go
down easily and asks oralis why you lure
him there back with Tomah Lisa diagnoses
the injured girl and says that some
light treatment would suffice Toma asks
her how she knows this and she replies
that she knows more about blood flow
than most people she then asks Tomah to
assist her as she AIDS the girl
Toma advises her to escape from the
school Isa tells him that she is not
being held against her will and that she
has her own objective for staying in the
school she tells Tomah that she is there
in order to avoid attracting and killing
vampires with her blood she tells him
that vampires are just like regular
humans and she doesn't want people to
die because of her she says that she
made a deal with oriolis he will cure
her of her ability to kill vampires in
exchange for luring a vampire to him
when she somehow needs to save someone
however their conversation is cut short
by the arrival of Orioles himself Toma
tries to attack him at point-blank range
but somehow misses he tries again but
this time Orioles somehow moved to a
concertable distance away from him
Orioles tells him to fade away but is
cut off by Iza she tells oreolus that
Tomah does not know the significance of
deep blood and came to the school to
rescue someone he had met just a few
hours ago
she tells a realist that if killing
civilians is his objective then she will
quit and kill herself because of this
Orioles does not kill Toma he takes out
a large needle from his pocket and stabs
himself in the neck with it then tells
Tomah that he will forget everything he
learned here in the building the scene
cuts to the outside of the school index
had followed the magical Aura from the
runes around tomah's apartment to the
building she enters the building while
Tomah and style are sitting on
playground swings in a nearby park Dazed
and Confused remarking that they had a
vague feeling that they had forgotten
what they are supposed to be doing
however when Tomah scratches his head
with his right hand he remembers
everything that occurred in the building
Tomah then instructs style to close his
eyes and stick out his tongue because he
knows of a charm to erase his doubts
style somehow obliges but is then
punched in the jaw by Toma which dispels
his memory loss as revenge for using him
as bait a while ago inside the building
index comments that there is a seal set
up to prevent Intruders from escaping
style and toner returned to Misawa kram
school just in time to see the force
sources of the 13 nights of the Roman
Catholic Church guarding the entrance
the knights pull out their swords and
invoke the real Gregorio choir style
Muses that the
333 monks are probably sending their
prayers from Street Peter's Basilica
Tomah asks what they are doing a style
tells him that they are going to bombard
the school clouds gather above the
building as lightning and thunder wore
out suddenly a large flash of lightning
strikes the building and it slowly
collapses however the collapse suddenly
stops in mid-air and the building
inexplicably begins to rise and repair
itself as if time were rewinding while
the knights look helplessly on the
tremendous power Orioles Tomah then
notices a familiar headdress on the
ground with a cat underneath it and
suspects that index has somehow gotten
involved in this meanwhile Orioles
carries an unconscious index into his
office and gazes down fondly her
tomlin's style have returned to the
school building
style is somehow confirmed where
Oriole's office is and they are now
heading towards there
Tomah Ponders on how they are going to
save ASA and now index who he feels has
now gotten involved with the situation
from a man who can do anything just by
saying it the scene cuts to Orioles and
ASA with index on the table sleeping
Orioles tells Aza that the grief with
her powers will be over soon and that
she now needs to lure a vampire however
both Toma and style arrive in oriola's
office and where Tomah confirms that
index truly is in trouble style tells
Orioles that he will not allow Orioles
to attain his objective style tells
Tomah that Orioles simply wants to turn
index into a vampire to Orioles
regardless of the consequences index
will still be saved Orioles says that
style should understand him as he too
has experienced what happens to index
every once a year hearing this style
states that index has already been saved
by the young boy next to him style tells
him that Orioles may have not heard the
news since he is in hiding Orioles
responds to the absurdity of the
situation by stating that Tomah is a
normal human not even a magician or an
alchemist
he is however told by style that Tomah
has with him in his right hand the
Imagine breaker a power that is beyond
what humans have style M service is his
position all of his efforts to cure
index were completely in vain and tells
him that index is completely happy with
Tomah as her partner there is a moment
of silence between them however it is
broken by index calling for Toma and
wanting some food style finds this
hilarious and laughs as well as Toma
suddenly Oriole has commands them to
fall to the floor angered that his
efforts were trampled on Orioles takes
out one of his needles and stabs himself
in the neck but before he can State his
command azus stops him she tells him
that she understands his feelings and
tells him that what he is doing is not
right however while doing so Orioles has
already stabbed another needle into his
neck and commands her to die causing her
to fall to the floor at the same time as
this Tomah breaks out of oriola's kamam
at biting his own thumb and catches her
Toma holds azith in his hands calling
her name Orioles laughs and comments on
how he doesn't need deep blood anymore
and how he has kept his promise as she
will be released from the curse of her
own blood through death
however eases suddenly moves and gasps
for air signaling that Tomah has
dispelled aza's death through Orioles RS
magnet by using imagine breaker Orioles
is obviously shocked by this but is told
by Tomah to shut up already and declares
that he will destroy his illusion
Toma charges towards Orioles who uses
his RS magnet to attack him Toma however
dispels everything Orioles throws at him
with his imagine breaker attacks like
Suffocation electric attacks and
summoned cars falling from the ceiling
seeing this Orioles confirms that his
right hand can dispel his RS Magna
without exception he postulates on what
would happen if Tomah was attacked by
something that Tomah cannot touch his
right hand
using his RS Magna Orioles specifies a
pistol that can fire magical bullets
that exceeds human motion recognition he
demonstrates an attack destroying the
wall behind Tomah feeling confident
Orioles says that he won't kill Tomah
easily and wants him to entertain him
more using RS Magna he conjures two
pistols with several barrels on them he
fires several bullets on Tomah and it
hits him however it seems that Tomlin is
uninjured Orioles laughs and reminds him
that he won't kill Tomah easily Orioles
prepares to fire another set of rounds
on Tomah but is interrupted by style he
asks him why he needed deep blood which
somehow angers Orioles he continues on
saying why he did not use RS Magna to
create a vampire himself if his words
can truly distort reality
infuriated with what style said he
commands him to float above to the
ceiling and is ripped off of all his
skin exposing his innards
this makes Tomah almost vomit at the
sight of the now horribly disfigured
style floating above him however Tomo
realizes something he stands up and
begins to realize why Orioles could not
just command index to be saved while
thinking this oreolus changes his pistol
to be capable of firing a blade at the
same time as this Toma realizes that
Orioles does not distort reality through
his words however Orioles has already
fired his blade and slices tomah's
entire right arm off of his body with
blood gushing forth
believing that he has won Orioles last
in his victory however Tomah suddenly
laughs as well and is smiling and
deranged and frightening manner he is
still alive
coma walks slowly towards orlus and
seeing him a live Orioles fires another
Blade with the intent of beheading him
but somehow misses completely he repeats
the same process but instead uses
several blades he however still misses
Tomah completely Oriole is now agitated
uses his RS magnet to summon several
Guillotines above Tomah to cut him but
are all dispelled completely once they
reach him Tomah suddenly talks to
Orioles mocking him and urging him to
use his power to distort him Orioles
panics and Spills several of his needles
on the floor while being mocked by Toma
he runs towards the table obviously
frightened on how his arms magnet is not
working on him however while looking up
he sees that style has come back down
and is completely alright carrying index
and smiling smugly at him Orioles keeps
telling to himself that with his power
he cannot lose to Toma in style he turns
around and sees that Tomah has already
quartered him and still mocking him
while smiling telling him the true
nature of his RS Magna that it does not
distort reality with his words but
distorts reality with his thoughts due
to the side of of Toma Orioles believes
that he's a monster and suddenly a
dragon head replaces tomah's entire
right arm and attacks orlus with it
the next day Tomah is in a certain
hospital being treated by the same
frog-faced Doctor Who is amazed himself
that the reconnection surgery was
successful and asked him if his body is
made of fantasy he is later visited by
style who has brought a fruit basket
with him he states that he is visiting
not because he wants to befriend him but
to see how he was doing style says that
the dragon that formed his toma's right
arm was the despair Orioles felt in the
11th Hour Toma asks what happened to
Orioles and style replies that he lost
his memories and the ability to do magic
but did not kill him they changed his
form and released him so the Roman
Catholic Church would not hunt him
anymore
style also knows that Misawa cram school
has been closed down their conversation
is interrupted with index going inside
the room at which point style disappears
instantly index clients on top of
tomah's bed and tells him that she has
heard on how he has fought for Isis sake
this time Isa comes in and is asked by
Tomo why she is with index index tells
Tomah that Iza one to thank him no
matter what as such she escorted her to
his room he's asked him why he saved her
even though they only met once in a
restaurant Tomah replies to her question
but he doesn't need a reason to save
someone which surprises Aza the end be
sure to subscribe and hit the
notification Bell to not miss the next
part